hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we're going over 15 things i
wish
i knew before going to a coding bootcamp
for those of you don't know i went to
flat earth school
exactly a year ago like i was in flat
art school exactly a year ago but my
time there was specifically from june to
october so summer to fall of 2020 and
yeah there are a few things i would have
liked a heads up for and so i'm hoping
to provide that all for you today so
let's get to it number one bootcamp
won't get you the job you got to do that
yourself and
what i mean by this is i feel like a lot
of people have the notion of oh i'm
gonna go to boot camp so i can get a job
or once i get through boot camp then
done like i'll be employed and then boom
we're good
all's great
and that's not really how it goes really
the mentality should be i'm gonna go to
boot camp so i am employable
but all the work of job hunting and the
stress and recruiting and interviews is
still on you that that isn't lifted
because you went through boot camp even
if they have career services available
even if they have aid and assistance
it's still you and it's a lot it's
stressful it's like a full-time job all
in itself but yes start preparing
yourself now that way when that moment
does come you're not like what just make
sure you understand that bootcamp is
there to make you employable you won't
just now by default have a job number
two bootcamp teaches you how to code yes
however
they more teach you
how to learn and this i don't need to
roll your eyes at this because this is
actually a really great thing about boot
camp because when it comes to developers
and getting jobs and software engineers
i didn't realize this before i was in it
but a lot of people learn
what they learned on the job like yes
they may have had a work programming
language in python and javascript and
all of this but then they went out and
ended up at a job in
front end design in react and now they
have to learn on the job and whatnot
well by going through a boot camp now
you know the best ways to learn now you
know you're learning style and you know
how what kind of
learning process you should
obtain to make sure you get the fastest
results possible because that's what you
did all through boot camp and that's a
great great thing that's actually
something that makes you more hirable i
know when i was going through interviews
from my current position that was one
thing that my interviewer said he was
like oh my gosh you're a boot camp guy
we're trying to get more of you here
because you guys are quick learners
you're hard working and that's a great
thing that we want here and so no that's
not a bad thing that oh they teach you
how to learn like no it's a great great
thing and you should actually be excited
about that number three there will
always be something to do so you gotta
be the one to set the boundaries this is
something i did not do at all at all who
was up at 3am coding lessons and plans
and projects out when everyone else was
enjoying time in their bed sleeping
me
me because i
just became so obsessed with i have to
get through this i have to get through
this i need to have a job afterwards i
need to make this money worth it and so
i didn't set those boundaries and it
really took a toll on me for those 15
weeks and so no set those boundaries
early because a lot of my classmates did
i couldn't reach them past like 5 p.m
because they set those boundaries of no
like after i it is 5 p.m and once i have
dinner on the table no that is it my
laptop is off and you cannot reach me
and i wish i had said that and so no set
those boundaries early and often because
when you're on the job you'll still need
to do that there's always something you
can do there's always something to do
there's always ways you can make
something better there's always
something some type of project you can
develop and you need to be able to
put a line saying yeah there's always
something to do and so i know when i
wake up it'll be there so yeah goodnight
y'all so yes set those boundaries early
and often and it will hopefully
help you have a more stable boot camp
experience number four um no matter how
much you say it's worth the cost of an
isa it is still going to hurt
like crazy when it's time to pay for it
and isa is an income share agreement
when i was going through boot camp was
one of the ways i could choose to
finance my time at boot camp because i
had a solid 15 bucks
in my bank account not 15 000. and so
the agreement is they loan you
you know in terms they loan you 15 000
and then once you graduate and have a
job you now pay them back 10 of your
gross income and so it's all sounds
great when you're trying to make this
transition but then it's time to pay for
it and you're like oh my
what and so now imagine making a hundred
thousand dollars and now every month
you're paying them one thousand and so
it hurts i'm not saying i regret it or
anything because to be honest i wouldn't
have the salary if it wasn't for them in
the first place you know what i mean but
it still hurts uh so prepare early don't
be shocked when they come knocking at
your door on your first day of work
demanding their money back but i
have heard some of y'all say that they
no longer offer isas i don't know if
that's why it's spread throughout the
entire
nation throughout the entire flat iron
school business or if it's different
programs i really don't know but yes
during my time they offered isas and i'm
quite grateful that they did because i
wouldn't have been able to go through
boot camp if they didn't number five the
community you are in is unlike any other
community you'll be in ever i
truly still think about that community
we had while in flat iron school we
called ourselves the love bubble it was
the most supportive and authentic and
beautiful community i've ever been in
and i honestly don't know if i'll ever
get that again and it's scary to say out
loud because i really don't know but
enjoy that time because
there are very few people who will know
what you're going through and
that's them that the people around you
that's them and that's such a beautiful
thing actually because you support each
other even more knowing that fact and so
really really cherish that really
appreciate it because yeah i truly have
never been in a community like that and
i truly don't know if i'll ever be in a
community like that again which is very
sad because also i'm grateful i had the
chance to be in one number six the first
eight weeks go by insanely quick
insanely quick but
the last eight weeks oh my gosh you feel
like you are in the trenches for years
four years i think
that was more because of
my
inability to set boundaries and so i
would be staying up and doing all these
things and then by the tail end of
things i was just exhausted
so exhausted i just couldn't take it
anymore and so time moved so slowly to
for me because i was just in such pain
now a lot of you i was in such pain and
agony and i was like please let this be
over and so by making sure you're
starting off with sending those
boundaries and pacing yourself and just
remaining a lot calmer than i did during
boot camp hopefully you don't have this
experience which is why i'm sharing with
you all these things so you can do
better than i did but yes the first
eight weeks went by very quickly because
it's still filled with excitement and
it's the newness of everything and all
of this and then by the last eight weeks
it's like yo i just want a job i just
want a job if you can just hire me i i
just want a job and so it's just the
focus kind of switches and that very
much
affects
your feeling of
the time movement during the program
number seven they don't teach computer
science so the point of boot camps or
yeah the overview point of them is to
make you employable get you
learning about the
trending technologies and languages and
the popular things to know so that when
you go start applying for jobs you are
hireable
that being said they don't teach
computer science and what i mean by that
is they don't teach algorithms and data
structures which is
like quan quote fine
depending on the job you're trying to
get but where that ends up being a
problem is during the job hunt because a
pretty popular part of the job
recruiting process is the technical
interview and so it's really rough
having all these skills that you've
obtained but you can't really showcase
them until you get the job and you're
not going to get the job without doing
these technical interviews and you're
not learning them through boot camps so
you have to take extra time away from
your learnings and lessons and projects
and do that yourself and so prepare for
that i if i had truly understood this i
definitely would have put time aside
let's say 30 minutes a day an hour a day
two hours a day at the tail end or
middle or lunch or whenever to add that
curriculum to my day that way when it's
time for me to go through the job hunt
process it's not me trying to play catch
up and that's not a fun place to be
because you're already stressed with so
many other things you're still in boot
camp you're still trying to pass but
you're still now your job hunting on top
of it and interviewing and now you're
also trying to learn
data structures and algorithms and so
it's just not a fun time and so let this
be a word of warning put that in right
now you can easily just go to like leak
code and just practice easy things and
you're not gonna know how to answer them
right now and that's okay that doesn't
mean that you shouldn't be practicing
them you're not to know right now the
first few days the first few weeks but
you'll get there you don't want to start
you're not knowing when you're trying to
get a job that's all i'm saying so yes
practice early practice often and
hopefully your transition to a job is a
lot smoother
eight the pandemic will actually make
boot camp a lot more efficient and
dare i say enjoyable for me i think it
made it more enjoyable and just less
stressful because
now that everyone was online when you
were in a lesson and you couldn't have
get your code to look like your teachers
then your teacher would just be like hey
share your screen and now you're sharing
your screen and they say oh line 23
you're supposed to have an if statement
not a for loop and everything and then
boom they go back to the lesson and now
you're on the same page instead of being
in a classroom the teacher has to walk
on over to your desk lean over
oh line 26 and then walk on back you
know like it was so much more efficient
pair programming if you had extra time
in your day saying hey who wants to pay
a program for the next hour now you set
up a zoom link and boom three people are
in the room with you it just made things
a lot more quick and streamlined and i
really appreciated that and i'm
especially mentioning this because you
know we are still in this parent teacher
conference i it looks like that this is
where we're really squatting and sitting
down and laying up camp and so if that's
a reason you are thinking about delaying
boot camp or you're unsure about boot
camp no actually i think it made
things go a lot smoother number nine you
can get held back
i did not realize this when i was
signing up and so when
it's first day and they're talking about
all of that i panicked like crazy i came
like crazy i was like what you can get
held back
but i'm trying to
make a life for myself and so just
prepare that now because if i had
understood this earlier i would have
been able to calm myself down like nia
yes you can help get held back like
every other thing in your life like high
school like college like your job yes
you can get help back if you're not
meeting the standards
for continuing on through these programs
of course and so i would have prepared
myself that way saying like yes you can
get held back and so what that's never
stopped you before that's never made you
more stressed out before it's just okay
i can get help back and so i'm going to
make sure to do the work and science
he'll deliver it's done and so yes know
that if you are failing code challenges
and really just not
really just not keeping up with things
they're not going to keep on tearing you
through
to the finish line like no they're going
to recognize that try to help you make
sure that you can catch up but
if if you can't like like college if you
have all of these f's at some point you
can't get to the next class because the
next class required you to have a
passing grade in all your previous ones
and you don't have that and so there's
really nowhere to go but home and so yes
just keep that in mind well maybe not
keep that in mind but just mentally
prepare but don't let that
cause any angst because like i said
that's like every other
aspect in your life like your
friendships if you're not you know
keeping up to par with what's expected
of you in these relationships well then
you're gonna get cut probably so yeah
just don't let that feel too much space
in your head number 10 some people will
really hate the fact that you went
through coding boot camp
and they went to
college and got a computer science
degree yet here you are living your best
life even though you didn't have to
take the years and
tens of thousands of dollars
worth
to get a degree so
keep that in mind well maybe not even
keep that in mind but just a little
sprinkle of caution there some people
really let that live in their head rent
free the thought that you went to a boot
camp and still ended up where they are
but you know at the end of the day that
is a conversation for them and their
therapist that has nothing to do with
you you just keep doing what you're
doing i just wanted you to just
get a heads up little sprinkle of yeah
just
there you go number 11 you will not be
able to work while going through boot
camp so i was in the full-time software
engineering program so if you're in a
full-time program yes you will not be
able to work at all and they say this
but i really want to iterate this
because maybe you're like me and you're
like oh they're just saying this but
they don't know me they don't know how
driven and how
i can make things happen and determined
i am no matter what my circumstance and
i can have a job i can have two jobs and
still knock this out of the park they
don't know me no no no
no
um no you cannot you cannot and
remember that thing about being held
back yeah well your
shots of being held back just shoots up
if you have a job because
now the time that you're spending at a
job
takes away from the time that you could
be learning and so really prepare ahead
of time like i moved in with my parents
like i moved in with my parents so i
didn't have to worry about rent food
utilities survival i didn't have to
worry about all of that it was really up
to them and i really just focused all my
mental space on boot camp and curriculum
and lessons well yeah you need to
identify
ways to make sure that you are not
worried about those same things during
boot camp you can start saving so that
once you start you can quit your job you
can have this book of savings to support
you you can talk to your spouse like hey
remember those vows we took yeah well
this is the plan so
just prepare ahead of time that way no
mental space is taken up on stress that
doesn't have to do with boot camp
because if you've heard me talk up till
now you know it was a struggle um
a happy struggle a struggle that i am
grateful for having gone through but it
is still a struggle and you don't want
it to become more of one because you are
worried about your next paycheck now
that being said i know not everyone can
move in with their parents and save up
money and all of that and so they have
options for having let's say part-time
bootcamp so that you can go to work or
fully self-paced boot camps so that you
can do all that but yes if we're going
full-time then yes that is my those are
my thoughts on that number 12 it
literally never lets up it never
lets
up i remember reading this tweet once
maybe some of y'all have heard it it's
like being an adult means saying
i just need to get through this week
every week
until you die
that is boot camp that is boot camp you
just say oh i just need to get through
this coding challenge oh i just need to
get through these projects oh i just
need to no
no girl you just need to get through the
next 15 weeks like there's no skirting
around it because the next week is gonna
feel like this week and the week after
and the week after and so stop
don't frame your mind like that like oh
i just have to get through this and get
through this and get to this because
then it just feels like you're playing
catch-up all the time and you're just
running all the time to this like
unattainable thing of next week's piece
and so instead really just acknowledge
where you are right now like yes i'm
busy yes i'm stressed but let me take
the next hour to walk around the park
and enjoy that and just that and then
come back to it all and
we're back and so yeah really make time
to actually enjoy where you are because
it's not fun spending 15 weeks feeling
like you just need to get somewhere else
and then you can be happy that's not a
good place to be so yeah word of caution
there number 13 you're not going to
learn everything i think this is also
another misconception when it comes to
boot camp of oh i'm going to learn
everything that he needs to know and i
will then have a job and everything will
be sprinkles and rainbows and all things
sunshine and that is not true at all
with 15 weeks that's not much time at
all people don't learn everything in 10
20 30 years of being in this industry 15
weeks is nothing so really their focus
is teaching you one thing well so
teaching you one back-end technology one
front-end technology one back-end
framework one front-end framework and
teaching you to build yeah web apps and
maybe mobile app development and calling
it a day there again this is my
experience from going through the
software engineering
program but yeah software engineering
isn't just
javascript and ruby
that's that's nothing that's just
like that's nothing so they really just
focus on teaching you one thing well so
that you are employable for that general
thing and that's not a bad thing at all
especially when we tie it back to they
teach you how to learn because now by
knowing that one thing by knowing ruby
now you can learn python exponentially
quickly because it's a very very similar
and now again you know how to learn in
the best most efficient way possible and
that's a great thing that's a great
skill to have as a person and as an
employee and so yeah get out of the
thought that oh they're gonna teach you
everything like no they're gonna teach
you one thing well number fourteen near
the end is so hard because you can see
the finish line you can see the finish
line and you're so tempted to be like oh
it's right there okay so let me take a
breath then boom you trip everyone
stampedes past you and now you're at the
hospital like
like i know that was dramatic but
basically yeah it's hard to keep up with
the pace when you start seeing that
finish line right there well i'm here to
tell you keep up with the pace y'all do
not drop off there i saw people who
had that experience of they were so
close and then oh shoot where are they
oh they got held back and so that's not
you know fun at all so make sure you
don't let the fact that you're so close
be why you give yourself a
more of leeway in your courses in your
projects and that you end up
not graduating that's not that would be
terrible and so just know that ahead of
time like yes the end is going to be so
difficult to keep up pace but you're so
close so keep on going that way you can
just run through that finish line and
throw your hands up and be so proud of
what you've just accomplished so yes
don't let up but like word of caution
i'm not saying don't take a breather
like i've been saying through all of
this like no learn to take breathers
learn to take time for yourself but
still keep up still
learn still be motivated don't let being
a week away two weeks away three weeks
away be the reason you abandon your past
process of oh i'm going to learn from
these hours and then from these hours
from these hours i can have projects and
all of that and now saying oh well i'm
so close i'm just going to take a nap
and watch these shows and call it a day
like i'm so close anyway no please
please please do not do that and number
15 it is the best decision i will ever
make um and i'm saying i because these
are things that i wish i knew
before boot camp and yes it is the best
decision i will ever make at the age of
on what what day is it august something
august something 2021 it is the best
decision i'll ever make it put me on
this trajectory i never could have
imagined for myself at all at all where
i am working at a company i adore i have
a salary i never
thought of having as a starting salary
as a person just gone off college like a
year ago
it'll put you on a trajectory like crazy
and then the people you meet the
community you build the oh my gosh it's
truly inexplicable
and i hope you have that same experience
but for me that a thousand percent was
mine and so if you know featuring me
could have ran down to the me up at 3am
stressing about lessons and everything
and saying yo you got this this is the
best decision you'll ever make i would
have maybe taken some time to you know
enjoy the outside and you know be happy
about where i am instead of obsessing
and stressing about where i want to be i
would have enjoyed it a little bit more
so yes there we go everybody 15 things
that i wish i would have known before
coding boot camp if you are thinking
about coding bootcamp if you're
currently going through them i hope this
video is able to provide you with some
helpful tips and yeah just words of
caution and you are able to yeah have a
good overall learning experience and so
there we have it everybody let me know
in the comments which things took out
which items stuck out with you most but
no thank you so much for coming like and
subscribe and i'll see you all later bye